[Music]
welcome
to the week in 60 minutes from spectator
tv recorded on thursday
january the 21st this week joe biden
becomes president on his third attempt
we'll look at what to expect from the
biden administration
britain's vaccine rollout continues to
general the claim
but has it slowed recently and what
should the government do about those
who don't want to be vaccinated and
russian opposition politician alexa
navalny returned to moscow and was
immediately arrested
what to make of this brave and
provocative figure
if you subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel and why wouldn't you
it's free
you'll never miss a program just click
the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now
now before we begin
a very special thanks to charles stanley
for their continued support of the week
in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
we're delighted that there are partners
here at spectator tv
first america has a 46th president
the oldest ever to take office and in
the most
unprecedented of circumstances with mobs
rampaging through capitol hill
the pandemic still raging in the country
and deep divisions
across the nation is president trump
really the right antidote
to four years is president biden really
the right antidote
to four years of mr trump i'm joined by
kate anders i'm resident american
who's penned a hopeful cover a piece for
the magazine
this week uh kate uh
you said that biden was lucky unlucky
what do you mean by that
this is a quote from former senator ted
kaufman
in evan osnos's biography of joe biden
published late last year
in which he says that joe biden is both
the unluckiest and luckiest man he's
ever met
the former he's referring to the
personal tragedies that joe biden has
experienced
he lost his first wife and his infant
daughter in a car crash
right before he was first sworn into the
senate
and he of course lost his son beau biden
several years back
very early as well so this is a man
who's experienced great tragedy and
on the other side a lot of political
luck despite
running for the presidency twice and
having failed presidential bids
he now finds himself uh securing more
votes for a presidential candidate than
any other candidate
in history he has found himself in the
white house
in the most fragile and difficult of
times but
actually things could be looking up
relatively soon he's coming in when
vaccines have been secured
the development of the johnson and
johnson vaccine in the states which is a
one-dose vaccine that needs to be stored
at fridge temperatures could be a real
game changer you can take that into
rural america
go door to door and the economy is
expected once people are properly
inoculated
to start surging again so well things
look very bleak now joe biden might be
overseeing
a spectacular economic rebound and and a
falling death toll in america
mere months coming into the job so it
could be by the autumn by the fall
the biden administration could be over
the worst of the pandemic
particularly as you say with the johnson
and johnson virus uh
it's a one dose one as you point out and
the economy could be recovering in a
fair whack so
stick for six months and it could start
to look quite good for the biden
administration
it really could and one would argue that
that doesn't have a lot to do with joe
biden it has to do with developments
that were made before he entered
the oval office but still he's going to
benefit
from them and but the real task ahead of
joe biden isn't
governing it isn't any particular piece
of legislation it is bringing america
back together as the social fabric of
the country is just in
tatters and it's clear that biden
understands the weight of that
responsibility
since he was elected certainly in his
inauguration speech this week
his whole message is one of unity he
made very clear he will be a president
for all americans regardless of whether
or not
you voted for him that he takes this
task he said into his
soul and that it is his job to unite the
country
he will be tested on these words however
when he has to start speaking to the
republicans reaching across the aisle
and compromising to get
his legislation through now because the
democrats have secured a
very small majority in the senate they
could start ramming through
pieces of legislation albeit watered
down because
many of these votes require 60 votes and
then you do need
some of the minority party to come on to
your side or
as biden says he hopefully won't have to
do that he will speak to republicans but
this is about to be
tested whether or not biden is serious
about his message of unity but also
whether or not the republicans are ready
to come and meet him halfway obviously
this is a party that is uh
really shell shocked at the moment and
pretty much a mess on the floor
i think it's got quite hard to see mr
biden's a sort of fdr
kind of figure of franklin delano
roosevelt who
did do a lot to bring the country
together in the great depression after
19 he was elected in 1932
but it may be beyond even an fdr
we we see the number of people who voted
for mr trump
who still think the election was stolen
even a minority of those who voted for
mr trump
would not prepare to criticize the mob
the rampage through
capitol hill we see an element of the
democrats wanting to set up a sort of
black list of anybody
who ever worked or was close to mr trump
and of course the congressional
uh democrats anxious to continue with
the impeachment it's a
you know the rhetoric was fine at the
inauguration uh
kate but it's a it's a tough job to heal
america at the moment
very difficult and the cover piece
speaks to this
this week because joe biden is very much
alone in his party and
in wanting to find consensus wanting to
find center ground
many in the democrat parties see this as
an opportunity to lurch
to the left to get their policies
through and really to point the finger
of blame at
not specifically the mob that raided cap
the capitol building and the
president donald trump uh but to point
at all republicans the representatives
even potentially those
who voted for him we're talking about um
74 million americans
joe biden doesn't want to do this but
he's going to be fighting his own party
as much as he's going to be fighting
the republicans and you know it's quite
unfortunate andrew but i think you're
right that the task is so big it's not
obvious that he can do it on his own
i think to see real recovery and trust
in the institutions again to bring back
the millions of americans who still
believe that this election
was fraudulent despite there being no
evidence for that
is going to take more than simply the
president it's frankly going to take a
republican party
to own up to the mess that it made and
for a lot of those representatives to
change their tune
going into the midterm election in two
years time there has to be a completely
different attitude
before people start voting as to how
we're going to treat the outcome of that
race
and you know the president cannot do
that on his own it's going to require
everybody to pitch in
and i'm not sure there is appetite as
you say for people to do it right now
well i think you you raise an important
point it takes two to tango
and we don't yet know if the republican
party is going to
reform itself in a post-trump uh
way that makes it possible for a
moderate biden administration to reach
across the aisle in a number
of areas i mean there is an appetite
among mr biden's people
to do that certainly those closest to to
him
but he's not sure who they are going to
be able to
reach who's going to be there when they
reach across the aisle and we still
don't know kid either
is it going to be a post-trump
republican party i mean does
mr trump no longer having his social
media
does he just disappear into uh his
mar-a-lago readout in a morass of
litigation and debt-fueled financial
problems
or is does he see himself as common
as a second coming we don't know any of
that we don't the president
indicated in his last speech before he
left for florida that he would be back
we don't know what that looks like yet
we don't know if that's
creating a new political party there are
whispers of that
essentially that would be to the
detriment of the republican party
because he would
be splitting votes it's a little bit
hard for me to believe that donald trump
would want to put himself forward in
politics
again if he didn't think he could really
win that would be pure vengeance but
let's not put it past him
we don't know if that might be on a
media platform that he creates himself
now that he's been
booted off the mainstream ones but as
you say andrew this is going to be a
real divide in the republican party
on the one hand you have republicans who
are going to be wooed by those 74
million votes that came in
for the president who see opportunities
in a few years time potentially to
to take control of congress again and
then on the other hand you have people
like
the former governor nikki haley who also
served as ambassador to the u.n for the
united states
who is very keen to distance the
republican party from donald trump as
being
critical of the president and actually
has been for years
it's going to be interesting with with
no designated party leader
in opposition like you have here in the
uk this is going to be a lot of
infighting
and voters are going to decide which
kind of candidate they want to promote
in two or four years time and so we're
going to be watching that play out
in in in terms of maybe some bipartisan
areas i think the appointment of
avril haynes the first woman to be the
national security chief
that has been praised from both the
republican and democratic sides
and i think the main reason is because
she's tough on china and one thing
that's becoming clear in this biden
administration again we'll see if
rhetoric lines up with action
is that they're not necessarily going to
back away from trump's stance on china
i mean he'll be more diplomatic you
won't see as many social media spats
but this is an area where republicans
and and democrats are probably going to
continue
to unite around broadly speaking what
president trump was getting at in his
four years is
that which is that a tougher stance has
to be taken i think it's clear that mr
biden is not going to junk
the trump agenda entirely he's going to
pick up on it he's
going to keep tax breaks for those
lower paid mr trump gave keep the
criminal justice reforms that happened
under mr trump uh
it's interesting too that he's talking
about the added stimulus as being as you
point out in europe gate
an extension of what mr trump had done
and of course
a tougher line with china which started
under mr trump
now seems to be the washington consensus
so that may help
i would struck kate just a final point
by
how you said in in your cover story that
if you take
you know mr biden did not win by a
landslide by any means
um he's got a very slim majority in the
house indeed it's a little
democrats a little smaller majority than
it was before the election
he depends on the vice president's
casting vote in a
50-50 senate you add all that up and
it's a little bit like the american
equivalent of a british hung
parliament and that would suggest kate
to me that actually
you're only going to get things done if
you in these circumstances if you deal
from the center ground
yes and to be fair this is what joe
biden's experience
in in washington dc has been for decades
now
famously when president obama was unable
to negotiate with the republicans he'd
send in joe
and joe very often managed to find that
center ground
so he knows better than anybody else
what it takes
to get meaningful legislation over the
line and that is some level
of bipartisan support it's worth
pointing out that
senator chris coons was up for the job
of secretary of state
uh he's a senator from delaware very
chummy with joe biden and
biden actually has left him in the
senate um almost solely to be
his whisperer to the gop because coons
has a very good reputation as biden did
in in reaching out to the other side
it's something he clearly prioritizes he
knows from a history in washington that
you cannot get meaningful things done
without support from the other side so i
do think he's genuine
when he says that that will be his goal
but he has his own party fighting him as
well as the republican party and in that
sense
and he stands quite lonely albeit in
front of an american
people that just overwhelmingly did
elect his ticket
to go to washington to enter the oval
office and to start doing the job
okay thanks for that you can read kate's
cover story in this week's
edition of the spectator and remember if
you subscribe
to the spectator's youtube channel for
free you
never miss another episode you just
click the subscribe button
at the bottom of the right right of the
screen now
now britain's vaccine rollout per capita
continues to storm ahead of most other
nations
with around 5 million vaccinations
likely by this weekend
the success has roiled much of britain's
media which is
often at its happiest revealing
weaknesses in the government's
pandemic response and there has been
plenty of them
so this week it had to console itself by
wondering aloud if pfizer supplies
has slowed down and of course it fell
back on its old
favorite chestnut postcode lottery
uh failing to understand that unless you
keep a central grip
on the roll out as they have in scotland
which has hardly been a success story
then some regional variation is
inevitable
and it's not always the result of
incompetence either
but before we get on to the vaccines the
big news today
is about the react study from imperial
college london which shows in its words
the coronavirus infections are not
falling in england so what's going on
well
the spectator publishes covered data
every day on its new hub
at spectator dot co dot uk
data and here's editor fraser nelson
to take us through it fraser thank you
andrew yes the imperial react study
is certainly big news it's one of the
biggest studies taken in this country
there's something like
140 000 people who volunteer
to be tested and the findings were in
imperial's own words that the rate of
new infections was not
dropping in the early days of lockdown
now this
sent shockwaves around quite a few
government departments because ministers
had thought
things were getting better the lockdown
was doing pretty much
what people thought they were going to
do and that they might be lifted
in february and we might move back to
the tier
system but if this big study
contradicted that then it wasn't quite
clear
how you can reconcile what it was saying
with the official data
now let's go back to the start of the
current stage encodes
the kent variant we can see that this
started to rise
during the last lockdown now this was
what
really were administers that if it could
rise throughout
broke down two what reason was there to
think that lockdown three
might put a stop to it so if a new
variant had spread
certainly into london perhaps nationally
you can see a scenario where
infections were rising exponentially and
even the
most forceful tools at the government's
disposal wouldn't stop it
that was the concern and quite a
well-justified concern when lockdown 3
was announced at the beginning of
january it takes a while for the coveted
figures to settle but let's have a look
at what's happened in
kent and in london since then we've seen
a sharp decline
in both places of almost 50 percent
now the cases they can change what
really matters is hospital caseload
so let's look at covert admissions in
london hospitals
we can see them absolutely surging here
during december almost troubling during
that month
and reaching a peak of almost a thousand
admissions a day in january the sixth
now again let's have a look at what's
happened since then these admissions
have fallen to about 650
a day that's a drop of about a third
overall
the hospitals are still very stretched
that's true in london
it's true nationally it's especially
true for intensive care
units but we have seen a decline in the
number of admissions in london
which was the epicenter of this new
variant
now let's have a look at england as a
whole you can see there
that the positive tests which again take
quite a few days to settle
seem to have com peaked at about the new
year
and then declining so the same rough
trend all around the country
so this is the puzzle how do we
reconcile this official
daily data and the hospital data with
the imperial study
saying that the virus is not falling
well that's
a little easier to understand if you
look at how the imperial study
takes its data it does two big samples
the last one
was in january the six it started then
but it compares it to the previous
sample
which was taken at the end of november
and the beginning of december
so the imperial study missed both the
december surge and the january peak
now the imperial react study is one of
many studies now looking at covid there
are
for example we've got the zoe study run
by king's college
they say the number of new coveted
infections has been cut in half
since the new year peak that's one piece
of good news but overall
there's not much good news we can still
see the levels of covert even now
they're lower than they were in the new
year but they're still
far higher several times higher than
they were a few months ago
and we've got the death figures which
always lag infections
they're terrible and every day we're
seeing depths climb towards
almost the peak which we had during the
first wave there is no
reason to look in these figures and see
any reason to lower your guard
but nor is there any reason to think
that things are getting exponentially
worse
in january as had been rationally feared
at the beginning of the year
things do seem to be improving and there
does seem to be rational grounds for
hoping that when lockdown restrictions
are reviewed
in the middle of february we might be
able to move back to the tier system
raiser thank you for that it's
fascinating uh if you want to keep up on
the latest statistics
go to the spectator data hub if you go
to the home page of the spectator
uh you can see a link through and it's
updated on a daily basis with all
other latest figures and it's a good way
to test some of the arguments with the
actual hard statistical data
that fraser and his team have arranged
there francis nelson i will let you go
now editor of the spectator
busy time for you let's bring in our
political team james forsyth political
editor
katie balls his deputy james i i was
struck again by what you wrote this week
saying
that the the government's vaccination
policy is really is government's
economic policy explain to our viewers
what you mean
yes because the vaccination policy
determines how quickly
you can reopen the economy uh
essentially there is no hope of getting
the economy going
properly again until you have vaccinated
enough people now i think there will be
debates about the timing of when to do
that
i think one of the other big changes is
there is now a view that the uk is
making
a good progress and vaccination program
and you've got to protect that
so i think we are looking at much
tighter border controls coming
uh in in in the next few weeks or so
uh i think that even with the the the
government suspending all the travel
corridors so that everyone has to have a
negative test before they come to the uk
our quarantine rules are still
relatively lacks compared to other
places you can quarantine in a private
residence for example
i think that is likely to change we'd
like to go down a much more australian
model
of you've got to do it in a hotel or
some other government approved
facility and i think this is the
question i think there is a view that
just protecting the domestic economy now
is the most important thing how worried
uh
is the government these reports are that
the fisa there's
been some problems on the supply of the
fisa
vaccine what's the truth there so pfizer
is is
changing it's reconfiguring its factory
to try and create more vaccine
that has led to a drop in the amount of
supply of pfizer not just to the uk
government but to everyone
i think that makes meeting the uk's goal
of vaccinating
uh 13.5 million people by the 15th of
february that is going to be
tighter i mean the sense in government
is still what they can get there but
they can't afford any more supply issues
if they are going to do so
i think it is so worth noting that this
is this pfizer issue is
less of a problem for the uk than it is
for some other countries because
the uk is not as reliant on pfizer as
some other countries and it
has the oxford astrazeneca a fridge
based vaccine which is approved
that is easier to roll out logistically
now i think if you look at there was a
there were strong numbers yesterday
there was a dip earlier in the week
when you try and understand the dip
earlier in the week i i think the
clearest explanation i've heard is that
some of this is down to the fact that
there has been a big priority put this
week on vaccinating people in care homes
and that is just not as efficient as
these big max vaccination centers like
we've seen at salisbury cathedral
where you just bring huge numbers of
people through jab them
and then they move out uh and so i think
that that that has been one part of a
delay but i think that
the the 15th of february deadline is
tight but i think the sense is still
that they should be able to meet it
you also write this week and it's quite
a striking
uh sentence or paragraph is that
by the end of spring which i guess is
sometime in may
maybe beginning of may middle of may by
the end of spring
everyone likely to die from covid
will have been vaccinated i mean if that
happens
that's a huge advance james yeah so
jonathan van tan of deputy chief medical
officer has pointed out that
the 28 and a half million people or so
in that phase one priority group
they account for 99 of deaths in
hospitalizations
uh if you look at the kind of the
schedule which is
of vaccines the uk should be have been
able to vaccinate all of them
by as i say the end of spring and with
them having had two to three weeks for
that first
shot to take effect i think the question
then becomes you know how do you do at
that point
go big bang and release all of the
restrictions or do you keep some
restrictions in place because you worry
about
mutations in the virus that might occur
in this
situation because this is way beyond my
gcse biology but as it was explained to
me
as you vaccinate more people uh
the virus comes under more pressure to
mutate to survive
and so you don't want a big gap between
your moment of
vaccinating half a population and having
reached kind of vaccine-induced herd
immunity so
i think what you will see is them try
and speed up
the vaccination of the entire population
uh to so that you hit that level of
vaccine-induced herd immunity as quickly
as possible
katie how much pressure is the
government now under from its own back
benches
to kind of give a road map out of
lockdown
is that still there we know it has been
in the past or
are they just kind of looking at the
vaccination figures and so let's let's
just concentrate in
rolling this out of the moment what's
the dynamic there
yeah i mean i think there's some
pressure but to be honest i do think
that if we're looking at that lockdown
skeptic group
um i think the number in the way has
dwindled in terms of the number of tory
mps
really keen to pressurize the government
and go public and i think that's for a
few reasons we've seen really high death
tolls this week on a daily basis
i think a lot of people think you
actually need to get through this really
acute period before you start
pressurizing
too much on a roadmap i think the daily
vaccine numbers help
because it does mean that people think
they are getting some data
and so i i don't think that is where the
main thrust is and i think we saw last
week
uh i think i think it was on thursday we
had steve baker
send a message to his covert recovery
group comrades
and saying that we have to get an exit
strategy
we're losing support with the people we
need and everyone should get in touch
with the whip and say that this is a
going to become a matter of leadership
ultimately suggesting boris johnson's
leadership could be in trouble
if there was no road map but lo and
behold i think of an
hour or so at that story breaking you
had steve baker issue a quick retraction
on
uh social media saying he had full faith
in boris johnson
so i think even the most headstrong
figures
can work out that they may want an exit
strategy now
it is not the most effective time to go
i think that's going to be once you hit
the first four priority groups so
mid-february he hit the target yes
potentially an easing but
to be honest i think the point where the
government will move the most or has the
potential to
if the side can win the debate is once
you get all the over 50s and you do take
out the vast vast vast majority of
deaths
and i think it's working out when to
have that debate really
the the vaccine isn't just as james
writes uh
the government's economic policy would
seem
also kitty to be boris johnson's
survival policy
uh that's i would suggest that's what's
taken off
some of the pressure we we had commented
on spectator tv
as the year came to an end that um
if things didn't get better there could
be some real leadership challenges to
uh mr johnson come the spring or early
summer
uh the vaccine has changed that outlook
hasn't it
completely and i think that even if we
get to the spring and we're still under
strict restrictions whether it's at tier
3 or tier 4 in lots of areas
i still think his position will be safe
and you're not going to see what we were
talking about previously because
there is a road map and there'll be a
sense of you just need to go this
much further and we're getting to a
better place
and even you know speaking to red wall
mps recently
uh one thing i'm picking up is yes
there's annoyance over universal credit
uplift
yes at free school meals there's a few
bruising things but
ultimately what most mps say their
constituents keep talking about
is the vaccine rollout and that's really
providing them with some comfort because
that's the thing that is having the most
impact and for once it is a good news
story
james you mentioned uh one of the scary
things hovering over this good news
story
is the the fear i think in government
circles
that the virus mutates and you you said
it
the more vaccines there the more it does
start to mutate still to
to keep on going to evade the facts
um that that they think the vaccine
could be
tweaked to accommodate these mutations
but you might need to do that to go back
and start vaccinating everybody again
which is uh
the health thinks of that i think you
face some very difficult questions right
now
right now there's there's a simple
strategy for vaccination which is you
vaccinate those people who are most
likely to die
from covid if you ended up with a
mutation of the various where the
vaccines were considerably less
effective
do you go back and give those people
this tweaked vaccine
or do you try and give everyone some
base level of protection so
the first call on the tweaked vaccine
goes to people who haven't had any kind
of vaccine yet
i think those those decisions are very
difficult um
very tricky i think it is striking the
uh prime minister's questions
yesterday boris johnson was kind of
quick to stress you know
but that he used how confident he was
that the regulator would have proved
quickly a tweaked vaccine this is the
point that matt hancock made to fraser
and i when we interviewed him for the
magazine
i think they have a confidence that they
they now know
more that they that if as long as they
are just
changing the vaccine slightly in the way
that they do the flu vaccine
there would not be the same kind of
year-long approval process
that you had to go through in the first
place but as you say the logistical
challenge of
once more vaccinating huge numbers of
people
would would massively [ __ ] the
economic recovery
casey the other thing james writes about
is that even as the vaccine
has rolled out to millions and millions
more and there's a sense that the
lockdown can begin to be eased
in stages maybe going back in to the
tier system again as an interim stage
but the government intends to get much
tougher on the border on the
international border
uh and i can see the logic of that but
what a lot of people think
well why are you only doing it now
i mean i think a lot of people have been
thinking that for some time when it
comes to the government's policy on
borders it's been all over the place
and we had a reminder of this this week
when pretty patel admitted um during a
tory event
i think that she thought was private and
but who knows
ultimately that she had actually argued
for the borders to close in march
um okay that was advice boris johnson
did not take but i think everyone in
government now accepts this should be a
tighter policy
but but even you know when we tightened
it last time lots of tory mps said
this is exactly the point by which we
should be opening up so
i think if we get to a point where you
have vaccinated
the most vulnerable and the government
then bring in for example what james was
talking about so
hotel quarantine what you have in
australia
i think initially probably you will have
people say well
if this is what we need for normal life
perhaps it's a way but i don't think
it'll be too long before you start to
hear some serious
opposition yes on the tory back benches
in the sense that the uk is an
international hub i think other
questions about how sustainable that
is in the long term but two i think in
terms of the public as well i think
if you speak to you know uh people who
have family in australia
of people who live in australia yes you
talk about how they have
many fewer deaths and i think
objectively that's that's clearly the
best outcome but
it's not a policy that is without pain
and there's lots of stories about
how difficult it is having such a strict
border policy
um similar in new zealand okay james
we'll finish up with you on this just on
the the politics of it
uh in uh
from the beginning of the pandemic going
way back to march and
and during the summer into the autumn
after christmas
uh there were plenty of opportunities
for labor
to to act as opposition uh because so
much was going wrong
and they they did point it out but it
much good did it really do them the
polls have
never really given labour a a consistent
lead it's either been a tory lead or
pretty much even stevens the job for an
opposition
for kiosk labour party doesn't it now
become much
harder if if the overarching
sense of the vaccine is that at last
things are beginning to go right
yeah i think if restrictions are lifted
in the uk
before they are lifted in france or
germany
i i think people will think oh the
government did a pretty good job of
handling this crisis
despite the fact that the government has
clearly made as you said a slew of
mistakes in in this crisis
and i think the danger for labor is that
there's a kind of recency effect that
what people would remember is the last
bit of a crisis
where the uk got out of it quicker than
other countries
and i think that is the danger of labor
i think you see this some people in the
labour party are saying that you can't
delay the local elections in may because
if you do so you're trying to get a kind
of vaccine bump by delaying the polls to
july or september so
they would not be happy with that i
think that that is a that is an
interesting sign of where politics might
be going
if the government can manage to get this
vaccine roll out right
and you end up in a situation where it
was as frasier said last week where
the uk is one of the is the first
country in europe and one of the first
major economies in the world
to be able to say right we are you know
even even with these restrictions at the
border but we are domestically going
back to something
very close to normal and of course if if
it is able to say that
the public may well understand uh
tough restrictions of the border because
if it's going right domestically
you've got to control the border until
you're on top of it entirely
i don't screw it up by being too liberal
at the border
yeah i think there is a sense now that
protecting the domestic economy
is is crucial i was very struck by
speaking someone who
wasn't where i expected them to be on
this debate yesterday and they said look
the brutal truth is that you know it's
more important for the economy
to be able to keep coffee shops and pubs
open
than it is to be able to allow you know
hot shot
international business people to come in
and do deals you know there is a sense
that
those deals will either be delayed or be
done in some other way maybe on zoom
you know but that you know this is a
temporary thing
uh and you know the the the benefits of
of of reopening this summer domestically
fully
are are worth it and just but i think
also the sense that the downside risk
of some uh of having to the whole
vaccination program again are so
high but it is better to er on the side
of caution
right james and katie we'll leave it
there thank you
for joining us uh today on spectator tv
but we're not
leaving issues of the vaccine or covert
we're joined now by trevor phillips
times columnist
former head of the equality and human
rights commission trevor welcome back to
spectator tv now you'll have seen
research this week indicating that
nearly three quarters of black bricks
wouldn't take the vaccine do you do you
think it's really that high
yes i do i think that there probably is
a very high level
of vactine vaccine reluctant or vaccine
skepticism amongst minorities
and i make the distinction because
reluctance
is really about lack of knowledge or
lack of understanding skepticism is
something
rather more conscious and positive
and i think among some minorities there
is a significant level
of skepticism they know perfectly well
what's being said about it they just
don't agree with it
what's the the cause of this skepticism
uh if to use your word because it is
quite marked i see from this research
72 of black britons
unlikely to get vaccinated they claim
42 of those from pakistan and bangladesh
origin
it's still a high number but it's a lot
lower than 72
but also some quite high what can i call
it anti-vax sentiment
among east europeans too now that's
quite a varied group from
black britons to to british
citizens of pakistani in bangladesh
origin to those from east european
what what's causing the skepticism in
your view
well i think there are a couple of
things going on here and i'll just
preface it by saying
that a big part of this problem is that
the government and the authorities
have made a big play in the last six or
seven months
of saying how much they recognize
that ethnic minorities are more
susceptible or more at risk
actually they don't know that they
haven't really done
the work we don't know the data uh the
government
says this stuff but actually it can't
back it up and i can go into more detail
if you want no i understand
why that's why that's such a big problem
because it's a big issue in convincing
some of these groups
why do i think that there is vaccine
reluctance or skepticism
well first of all i just don't buy this
idea that's being put around
and ministers say this that oh it's all
about language and the communication is
not reaching them
if you look at the ons data the
proportion of people in this country who
do not speak english well enough
to understand that kind of information
is about what is 1.3 percent the highest
level of language a lack of language
proficiency
is uh bangladeshi women five percent
so this idea that basically it's all
about giving it the information to them
in their languages and so on brackets
they're all a bit backward
i just hate i really despise it because
actually it's a good way for official
them
to pretend that actually it's the fault
of these
minority communities and secondly what
it suggests
is that these people just don't know
what's going on if they
you know if we educated them a bit
better they they'd think the same as us
and it's a failure to recognize that
actually some of the
communities involved just take a
different
view about risk and about levels
of uh the value of vaccine and there's
one other thing which may explain
partly why the black figure let's call
it
though that covers a whole multitude of
kinds of people is so high
and that is simply distrust of authority
uh something similar is true in the
united states where african americans
are displaying significant levels of
resistance
to taking the vaccine and what we think
is going on there is very simply
we don't believe you and actually uh
everything you've done in the past has
really shafted us
and there's one other small point which
perhaps um
we ought to think about um and which you
know i'm
completely pro the vaccine but one of
the questions that one might
ask actually if you were from some
minority backgrounds is
has this been tested on people like me
and actually what we know about the way
that the
pharma company carried out their testing
is that they always do
have uh a deficit in
the proportion of people from minorities
you're a another distinguished british
citizen from a caribbean background jeff
palmer so jeff hammer who was writing in
the mail this week
he also mentioned the issue of trust um
he also wrote and i've remained to be
convinced about this
you take that there were there were just
too many white people up on that stage
from public school backgrounds and that
was the reason
can can that really explain 72 percent
well uh full disclosure jeff um
has been a family friend interestingly
enough
from the time he was a great friend of
mine
older brother so i've known him since i
was six years old
and i have great regard for him i think
he's a
you know he's a brilliant scientist and
so forth i think he's got his
got it around his neck on this one i
think actually the idea that if you just
had a few black faces on the platform
uh it's a variety of the same thing
that actually um if you
basically talk to the chiefs then the
chiefs will talk to the indians
and then it'll all be all right
i just think this is nonsense the truth
of the matter is that people are fully
conscious by and large
of what they're being told but
in for substantial reasons some to do
with cultural background maybe religious
beliefs
but also skepticism about what they're
being told by
any authority in this country they are
not
convinced why does this matter well it
matters because if you're going to
remedy that
simply to giving them the same
information just in another language
isn't going to crack it you've got to
address the fact that people have
different points of view
and this in a way goes to the heart of a
debate that we've been having 20 years
about multiculturalism
uh that you know you can all go kumbaya
and say okay we're all
the same under the skin and all the rest
of it but there will come a moment
and we may be coming to one where what
we discover
is that there are some people who
sincerely believe something
which is completely at odds with what
the
majority of the country believes and
what the majority of the country
believes
to be at odds with the interest of the
community as a whole
and at that point somebody's got to make
a decision
about how you deal with that
well to ask my favorite leninist
question
what is to be done
well i think uh the first thing is that
we you know you know that i bang on
about this
we've got to have proper information i
mean right now
everybody says constantly uh their
minorities are at greater risk well
actually the latest data
from the nhs on mortality shows
that the proportion of people who have
died who are white
is 86 which is exactly
the number that white people represent
in the population as a whole
so first of all we need to stop uh
spinning a narrative which is basically
the one that people would like to
to be true because it solves all sorts
of problems and deal with the facts and
that needs some work
secondly um and that and also if you're
going to persuade people you've got to
show them some actual data
so i would say that we first need to
understand who is at risk
and secondly we need to understand
better which
communities are truly reluctant saying
black people are more reluctant
which includes somalis and ghanaians
and bold agents who all have completely
different outlooks
you know some might be muslims some
might be christians we need to
understand
who is really vaccine skeptic and
why before we uh tackle the problem
so i think we need to do a bit more
research and be a bit more honest about
this
before we start throwing uh solutions
which frankly will have no impact into
the pot
i mentioned that i was a skeptical of
jeff palmer's
uh complained about too many white too
many public school boys giving out the
message
um but i do also see there is some
validity
in giving up messages to particular
groups
in the the in the manner in the language
by people that they regard as role
models and
that they look up to as exemplars of the
communities
that they come from and i'm not sure the
government has done much
or any of that i mean i know he's a busy
young man with a lot to do already but
someone like marcus
rashford uh or stormzy even
people like that they could they not
make a difference if the government got
them on side on this
only if they actually had a proper
answer i mean the fact that somebody is
black
is telling you something that you think
is nonsense
isn't going to persuade you any more
than if somebody is white gives you
something an answer that you think is
nonsense i think
whoever the messenger is we've got to
get the message
right first and my concern
here is that uh the way we're dealing
with this
somehow suggests that the only reason
that people might be vaccine
skeptic is because they just don't
understand
modern white people's ways i think we
first
have to address what is it that they
actually
are concerned about and make sure that
we actually have a
proper answer by the way i mean one of
the other things that's being said is
it's all about the conspiracy theories
that are going around
and that actually somehow minorities are
more susceptible to conspiracy theories
on twitter
i mean give me a break give
you know so first of all i think the
fundamental thing is i i get your point
but the first thing is treat the
minority
skepticism with the seriousness it
deserves
listen to why people think that there's
a problem
and answer it scientifically with proper
data if we can
who gives a message i don't care about
you may be right marcus rashford would
be more listened to than anybody else
but actually i'm not sure that's true
i think that the average minority person
will say
marcus rashford knows about football but
he absolutely does not know about
sticking
needles in my arm so the messenger does
matter
but what matters more is the message i
understand well we know government
people watch spectator tv so i hope they
were listening to you trevor
from what you had to say there thanks
for joining us again my pleasure as
always andrew thank you
thank you now our final segment on this
week's spectator tv on sunday
the russian opposition politician alexa
nalvani
returned home to a regime which had
previously tried to poison him
he'd been convalescing in germany having
survived a botched assassination attempt
at the hands of the russian secret
services uh
pictures and videos of his arrest as
soon as he landed were shared in real
time
on social media so was this a brave move
it certainly was but was it also stupid
owen matthews
he's a veteran russian reporter author
of stalin's children he writes
for the spectator on russian matters and
he's written
about what's been happening this week in
the current edition
of the spectator own welcome to
spectator
tv i mean let me just come straight to
the question that everybody is asking
who hasn't been following this
in detail he knew what they tried to do
to him they almost killed him he managed
to get out
he managed to recuperate in berlin and
he went straight back again
why um hello andrew good to see you
um he's a uh a fighter
i he is a proud man um i think he's
uh in many ways uh a vain man
um not to take away in any way not to
detract from his extraordinary bravery
in doing this
but i think the real question is um is
he really
going to prove anything with this great
act of self-destruction
that mikhail hadkovsky the oligarch whom
uh putin jailed back in 2003 didn't
already
prove and you can see in his court
hearing the first court hearing he said
this is a travesty of justice this is
ridiculous
and i think a lot of russians who saw
that
thought well yes we knew that you knew
that
why do you need to show that to us again
and
most importantly how are you going to
help your cause
by spending you know the next three ten
who knows years in jail i mean you
you point out in your article that i
mean he he hasn't just got back into the
lion's den if that phrase
ever had a meaning that what he's done
is going back into the lines then
he was even taunting president putin on
social media you report saying
here's president putin stamping his
little feet of the prospect of my return
i mean that's remarkable well and and
since then
um since since the uh the the magazine
came out he actually doubled down on
that because
after his arrest his team released
yet another video uh probably his most
ambitious and most extraordinary one
yet um which had already been prepared
he
clearly spent a lot of time uh preparing
this and it's all about putin's personal
wealth about in in detail
with all the accounts with all the
holding companies
with the names of how a gigantic
palace on the black sea coast personally
belongs to putin
about apartments that he bought for his
mistresses
uh mothers uh for for his illegitimate
daughter i mean it's absolutely
mind-blowingly provocative and
extraordinary shocking it's an absolute
journalistic bombshell
but now i mean knowing that that was
about to come out
immediately after his return to russia
it just makes the whole thing
all the more extraordinary and i think
it just proves that he
was clearly doing this in order to make
himself a martyr
he was not in any way expecting putin
not to react he did everything
to provoke putin into putting him in
jail
now he he was jailed before uh in 2013.
there were then quite a lot of
demonstrations in some cities
after that and he was then
released uh after that on certain
conditions but you think times have
changed this time you think
that mr putin and the kremlin that's not
going to happen again that they are
really ready to throw the book at him
this time
they certainly are i mean i think i
think that it was it was amply
demonstrated even
in december it was no surprise even in
december the prosecutor's office
announced that they were
uh they're opening a new criminal case
uh immediately after
his return they opened in yet another
one because he's apparently defamed a
war veteran
because their war veteran was one of the
people whom he quoted as supporting
putin said these people are traitors
i mean they're just piling on more and
more and more
accusations and narnia clearly knew that
uh quite apart from having been
in a coma for 20 days uh having been
poisoned by the fsb
so the i think the the the the
calculation is he thinks that the
kremlin is going to just like in 2013
be somehow cowed or scared by
street demonstrations now in 2013 russia
was gearing up to the winter olympics
and they were going to be it's going to
be in the world's eye
putin like all authoritarians loves
these sort of giant
international set pieces more than
anything and he
uh didn't want to have any kind of
uh uh
embarrassment which is why he released
uh
mikhail kadarkovsky before the sochi
olympics is why he wrote he
um handed down a suspended sentence to
navalny before the
winter olympics in 2014 uh but sadly for
navalny uh there were no olympics this
year
yes exactly what i mean he must have
known of the back of his mind
even at the front of his mind that
there's a huge risk
that he is just stuck in the slammer for
as far as the eye can see
in some god-forsaken russian jails were
prison some
somewhere and that's at the very least
was a possibility if not a probability
now
given that that was perhaps a
probability what
could he hope to achieve if that was to
happen
what can he achieve being in some
miserable jail
uh 500 miles from moscow
the most surprising thing about about
this calculation um
is that hitherto alexander vandy has
actually been a very brilliant
strategist in terms of how to overcome
putin's power
because uh both tactically and
strategically
so for instance he's very carefully not
taken really any sort of major political
positions
so his his uh the the way he's
positioned himself has been as a as a
critic
of official corruption and that's a
universal message he's not going to
alienate anyone
except for you know particularly stupid
and
and sort of mindless patriots who say
like no
our leaders are completely clean and
they never steal anything i mean
you won't find anyone in russia who says
that um but
navalny has not positioned himself as a
national politician
he's positioned himself as an
anti-corruption campaigner and that's
been sort of
strategically very smart and tactically
he's been very smart because
uh what he's done in various provincial
cities and is what he was working on
when he was poisoned
uh was one of his devastatingly
effective videos
on the municipal elections in
novosibirsk
and uh long story short with just 150
000 votes focused on opposition
candidates
united russia putin's party could lose
control
of russia's third largest city
so what his campaign he called this
calls it smart voting in other words
uniting participating
behind one opposition candidate and you
log on you find out who is the most
likely to win
everyone votes for him they win that is
actually extremely tactically
smart way of bringing down united russia
i mean it's hard to bring down putin
because he's
you know this god-like figure there's no
plausible alternative but
in terms of actually really eroding the
base of the kremlin's
support and the kremlin's power galaxy
the valley has hitherto gone about it in
exactly the right way
now everyone is baffled is that
what he's done now as you rightly say
he's going to be in jail for
several years everyone expects um his
last video that he put up the one that i
mentioned earlier about his putin's
palaces
uh got 30 i checked yesterday evening
had 31 million views on youtube
31 million views that's one third of the
voting population of russia i mean
that's extraordinary
reach that's devastatingly effective
although of course not all those views
were from within russia of course
but nonetheless i mean he's uh here the
two actually been a really dangerous and
smart opponent
and now he's actually seems to have just
done a catastrophic misstep
and i think uh the only reason that uh i
can think of is that he
believes that he uh his moral authority
from inside jail will somehow
spread and keep him in the news
and uh his suffering will in a rather
like a sort of tolstoyan
or probably more likely dostoevsky in
character
his movement will be ennobled by his
martyrdom
but in practical terms i'm not really
sure i think you're completely right
um a silenced navalny is a powerless
navalny
and he's brought that on himself
tell us just a bit about how russians
regard uh mr navalny i mean
is he a household name um is he still a
household name if you leave the big
cities
is he regarded as a martyr is he seen
as this sort of fearless uh crusader for
truth
what do most russians what's the
consensus view you think
of them inside the country well
um the uh the the most shocking um
um poll was done by the levada center
which is the the only thing
close to an independent polling station
and they signed and they
and they found um um in december that
only
19 of russians actually think that
navalny
was poisoned because he was an
opposition candidate
because he was in opposition to the
kremlin
uh 30 thought that he'd poisoned himself
a further um around 20 to 30 percent
thought that he uh that it was all sort
of some kind of complicated
uh um uh provocation by the
by by the west i mean the the the the
basic problem with navalny which you
correctly identify in your question is
that
beyond the cities he's not really that
very well known and certainly not to
those
people who still rely on state
television as their main
uh source of information i mean vladimir
putin literally and
rather actually now comically uh for now
for a decade has refused to say his name
like lord voldemort that the name the
violin has never passed the lips of
vladimir putin that just never happened
and if you watch russian state
television as i have been um
the last few days you know it's as
though it never happened and i've been
corresponding uh you know with with
literally dozens of friends and
acquaintances not just in moscow and
petersburg but
all over russia and for them um
i mean uh what struck me most of the
many
uh uh responses is that even people who
are quite sympathetic towards november
with his anti-corruption message
say he's an idiot like how can somebody
who
has so little regard for his own liberty
and his own
you know and his own well-being be a
leader that we could look up
to because he didn't you know
that his his principal stand comes
across
sadly to many russians because they've
been so permeated by this culture of
cynicism
that has been very deliberately
promulgated by the kremlin and his
critics
this sort of nihilism uh they just think
like you know what an idiot
like you know didn't doesn't he know the
rules didn't he know what was going to
happen
like you know yes the system is rotten
you know we knew that they steal yes we
knew that too so
um the the biggest problem for navalny
in his and his future in the future his
campaign is this sort of terrible
cynicism
and in this uh in in returning and being
imprisoned
i think he's actually if uh he's gained
the respect of people who look up to
martyrs and the fans of nicole irish
tolstoy and so on
but for just as many people think that
he's just you know a
fool and he's actually lost respect
among lots of people because you know he
and it was very clear you know as you
said right at the beginning of this
conversation like he survived he made it
he managed to buy a whisker survive this
this horrific poisoning attempt and was
home free he was in berlin
like why would you come back after that
and i think uh for
for the majority of russians i think
that sort of uh that
that sort of relegated him to the status
of some kind of um
you know hysterical religious almost
religious mata
um uh obviously in the cities which are
the politically important part
um there are the urban intelligentsia
who
think that he's a hero and will come out
uh this saturday on the streets um
and will doubtless have their heads
cracked but sadly that's still
a rather small majority a minority of
even
well listen thank you for that i'm going
to leave it there thank you for your
excellent piece in the spectator uh this
week
and for marking our card and what's
what's happening it's a fascinating
tale i didn't even go around to the fact
that the fsb
seemed to smear the the novichok on
uh his underpants uh and even then
didn't
i mean you couldn't make that up could
you oh and thank you very much all
matthew's uh there
that's it for this week thanks to all of
our guests and once again to our very
special
sponsor charles stanley they're
continuing support for the week in 60
minutes is much appreciated
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms in the london
stock exchange we're delighted to have
them
as partners here at spectator tv a final
reminder
if you subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel it's free
you'll never miss another episode you
just click the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now as
always please send
any thoughts to us at spectator tv
at spectator.co.uk that's spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk join us again
next week bye
[Music]
you